Out front with me now is James Clapper,
former director of national intelligence
under President Obama,
also retired lieutenant
general in the U.S.
Air Force,
and Ian Bremmer, president
and founder of the Eurasia Group.
Gentlemen, it's good to see you
this evening.
Director Biden
saying tonight that Ukraine doesn't
need F-16s right now, but Zelinski,
even today was calling again on the West
to provide them.
Who's right?
Well, I think
actually the lengthy is, to be honest,
I think the administration
is losing an opportunity here
to exert leverage
by simply announcing
that we're going to enter
Ukrainian pilots into training
and their maintainers
to support the maintenance
requirements in F-16
and then reserve judgment on
when and where to deploy them later.
The problem is
is these weapons systems
get more complex.
They require more lead time to train.
The Ukrainians
set up the supply and logistics.
So I think would be
it would be to show support
for the Ukrainians
and convey a message to the Russians.
If we simply announce
that we're going to
start a training program
for the Ukrainians, on the F-16,
because ultimately
maybe they don't need it today,
but they're going to at some point
because that's,
you know, air
defense is a requirement
for the Ukrainians
and the 16
as a capable air to ground attacker.
So I would respectfully suggest
the administration consider
announcing that
and then reserve judgment
on the actual deployment for later.
Is an interesting point
director that even the announcement
even though as we've seen with
all of the other
announcements and then
how the actual delivery comes
months months later for some of these
more complex systems
the announcement itself
can work as a deterrent
and send a strong message.
And just
broadly, as we're sitting here
on 365 days into this
where do you see this
four standing one you're in?
Well, for the last year,
the level of support
that the United States
and the allies have provided to
the Ukrainians has been extraordinary.
It's been
staggering really well beyond
what anyone would have expected,
including the Ukrainians
in the early days,
as well as the coordination
in punishing the Russians.
The big question is, can that persist?
Certainly you are starting
to see a reduction of support
among some Republicans
and certainly
among public opinion
of those that tend to vote Republican
as well. As among independents.
And the Europeans
are watching that carefully.
They're deeply concerned about it.
When I was in
Munich at the security conference
last week
speaking to a lot of Ukrainian officials.
You know,
they don't like this formulation
of the Americans saying
as long as it takes
because they feel like
time is not working in their favor.
They need as much as possible.
As soon as possible,
because if they're still
fighting in two or three,
four years time on their ground,
their economy
is going to be completely destroyed.
They're concerned about that.
The final point
is that China, of course, is now
playing a greater role.
And the fact that they put forward
this 12 point diplomacy plan
is not going to be accepted
by the Ukrainians or the Americans,
but it is going to be accepted
by all the developing countries
in the world.
In fact,
if you didn't know that China had written
this plan
could have easily come from India
or from Brazil or South Africa.
That's a problem for the United States.
It's a problem going forward
in terms of how this conflict plays out.
It's interesting.
You know, Director,
speaking of China,
from an intelligence perspective,
what do you think of this
new reporting that that U.S.
Intel suggests
that China is considering
sending drones and ammunition to Russia,
having American intelligence, even it put
this out there. Does what?
Well, I think it helps to
it's a good use of intelligence to exert
some pressure on the Chinese,
hopefully leaning on them
not not to do this, not to provide
weapons to
the Ukrainians,
not whether they will or not.
That remains to be seen.
But I,
I think this continues
a pattern of operationalizing
the use of intelligence, either
to pursue a military objective
or in this case, a diplomatic one
by dining out the Chinese in advance.
And hopefully putting some pressure
on not to provide
weaponry of any sort to the Ukrainians,
even when it comes
if China isn't deterred,
if they do decide to go ahead
and provide the drones and ammunition.
What do you think the United States
and its allies
should do if China crosses a line here?
Do you think the U.S.
should be drawing a red line on it?
I think one of the interesting things
over the course of this war
is that the Chinese,
for all of their support
of Russia diplomatically,
they they really have been
on the sidelines.
In fact,
actual Chinese policy towards
Russia has been virtually identical
to that of India,
which is, of course, much more aligned
with the United States.
If they were to provide direct military
support for Russia, that is a red line.
And that's why it's so important
that not just the Americans,
but also the UK prime minister,
the NATO's secretary general.
They all coordinated
in making these very strong statements
over the last few days
that there will be hell to pay
if the Chinese actually decide
they're going to put their thumb
on the scale in that way
in favor of the Russians.
I think you would see direct sanctions,
secondary sanctions
from the United States
against Chinese firms.
And while the Europeans
would have to debate this very strongly
because you know, their economies
are already getting hit a lot harder
because of this Russia war,
I suspect that most of them,
especially the Germans and the French,
would be aligned with the United States.
This is the exact opposite of what
the Chinese wants to see happen
going forward.
So I agree with Jim
was a good use
for operational intelligence.
And I personally would be quite surprised
if the Chinese went ahead
and actually did
provide these weapons in the near future.